on critique est quand même un peu le
côté backrooms ainsi oui je critique pas
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais il ya des
gens qui sont malheureux 4 que vous
précisiez pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne savent pas tous forcément ce que
c'est qu'un backrooms n'est pas une
épreuve de répétition pour les candidats
au bac n'ont pas de personne et tout le
monde sache ce que c'est qu'un pépin
batroun dans les boîtes vous savez vous
savez ce que ça j'aimerais bien y aller
mais moi je crois que les hétéros qui
vont dans les bordels sont malheureux
mais enfin je suis débordé alors été
shirt akrou m'attendais à ça comme ça
pas de marthe richard andré vieille
histoire ça non mais je dire ma choix
qu'il faut pas généraliser
ouais y'a pas il ya des surconsommateurs
sexuels qui sont très heureux il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas les battre dans les
bois dans les boîtes gays dans les
boîtes gays
il ya des endroits un peuple en noir
noir comme ça parce que nous on va on va
ou ne va pas on you il se passe des
choses assez libre disons 1 et il ya
déjà dédé il ya des parois comme ça avec
des trous dedans dans la paroisse qu'on
appelle des glory auch à la cause le
regard admiratif un accord alors le
glory hole on passe on passe bien j'ai
bien ri yong leur gueule on passe son
sexe c'est pas pour les filles on passe
son sexe en bleu hérault cette attitude
ne sais pas qui vous
valérie fait pipi mes repas non merci de
vous messieurs
je crois que dans l'oreillette qu'elle a
gardée au vient de lui dire il y en a 1
derrière le studio et les parties
vérifier en fait alors le bio vidéo vous
le glory hole donc c'est un petit round
ont accueilli les parois avec des
petites où on passe son sexe dont je
petit rocco siffredi tape le mur
derrière il ya quelqu'un qui vous fait
ce qu'il veut me savais pas qui s'est
beaucoup donné en relais me dites pas
que vous ne connaissiez pas les glorieux
mais moi je connaissais pas je connais
les accros je fais pas l'idiot mais je
ne savais pas qu'ils avaient sérieuses
savais pas que c'était comme s'il faut
comme ça que thierry est ce que vous
avez jugé dans un bac rom et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux